Let's take an example
site like udacity.com and
imagine that I am a user who has
difficulty reading small print.
Now naturally, one thing I may do to
help with this is to zoom the page.
So let's go ahead and we'll just
zoom this page up to about 400%.
Now an interesting thing
is going to happen,
we're now viewing the mobile
version of the site on our desktop.
Because the page was
designed responsively,
the UI has rearranged itself for
the smaller viewport.
Which is great for desktop users
who require screen magnification,
and it's great for
mobile screen reader users since there
are fewer elements to touch and explore.
This is just a total win, in fact, just
by designing responsively we're meeting
rule 1.4.4 of the WebAIM checklist.
Which states that a page
should be readable and
functional when the text
size is doubled.
Now going over all of responsive design
is way outside the scope of this course.
Fortunately, there is a separate
Udacity course just on this
topic which you should totally
check out if you get a chance.
I'll leave a link to this
down in the instructor notes.
But there are a few important
points which I did want to cover
which will be both important to
improve your responsive experience but
also to give your users better
access to your content.
The first of those is to make sure that
you're always using a meta viewport tag,
and that you're setting its
width equal to device width and
its initial scale to 1.
The meta viewport tag gives
the browser instructions on how
to control the page's dimensions and
its scaling.
By setting width equal to device-width
we're telling the viewport to match
the screen's width in
device independent pixels.
And by setting initial-scale equal
to 1 we're establishing a one to
one relationship between CSS pixels and
device independent pixels.
Doing this will instruct the browser
to fit our content to the screen so
that the user doesn't just see
a bunch of scrunched up text.
Now one thing to note, when using the
viewport tag, make sure you don't force
max scale to one or
set user-scalable to no.
This is a bit of an anti-pattern
because it prevents users from easily
pinching to zoom
the content of the page.
Which is useful if you have a hard
time reading smaller text, so
be mindful of this one.
The next technique is to make sure that
you're designing with a responsive grid.
As I demonstrated with the Udacity site,
designing with a grid
means your content will reflow
when the page changes its size.
So this is great for working on mobile
devices but it's also great for
those of us who need to zoom in the page
in order to read smaller text content.
Oftentimes these layouts are produced
using relative units, like percents,
ems, and rems,
instead of hard coded pixel values.
The advantage of using relative units is
that text and content can enlarge and
force other items down the page.
So the down order and the reading order
remains the same even if the layout
is changing because of magnification.
Now you might also consider using
relative units like or rem,
specifically for text size instead of
pixel values, as some browsers support
resizing just the text in a page
via a user preference setting.
If you're using a pixel value for
text, it may not zoom when
that setting is turned on.
If, however,
you've used relative units throughout,
then the text should update
to reflect that user setting.
Lastly, when your design is
displaying on a mobile device,
you need to ensure that your
interactive elements like buttons or
links have touch targets
that are large enough.
And have enough space around
them to make them easy to
press without accidentally
overlapping onto other elements.
This benefits all of your users,
but it's especially helpful for
anyone with a motor impairment.
A minimum recommended touch
target size is around 48 device
independent pixels on a site with
a properly set mobile viewport.
The 48 by 48 pixel area corresponds
to around 9 millimeters,
which is the same size
as someone's finger pad.
So in this case I've got two
buttons here and this top one is
actually about 40 pixels,
the one below it is about 24 pixels.
So to get up to this 48 device
independent pixel range what I can do is
I can add some additional
padding to each of these to make
sure that their final touch target
size meets this requirement.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now touch targets should also
be spaced about 32 pixels apart,
both horizontally and vertically.
So that a user's finger pressing
on one touch target will not
inadvertently overlap onto another one.
So while this icon here has
a touch target area of 48 by 48,
I'm also going to ensure that it has 32
pixels of margining around it to make
sure that it's not overlapping with this
other interactive element over here.
Following this set of guidelines will
go a long way to ensure your experience
is both easy to interact with and
accessible regardless
of the device size.